you see it's going to talk on making a
contribution to psyche learn which was
from the aho hackathon I think a little
while ago they focus yes hi everyone so
I'm Lucia and I work his data scientists
at the new UK at the moment you can find
the online everywhere basically if you
really want so I make my first
contribution to scikit-learn on HL
hackathon a couple of weeks ago so I
will talk about my experience and how to
have to do it for the first time so the
I in ideal world you should get in touch
with other contributors and ask them for
guidance you can meet them on hackathons
or meetups or you can ping them for a
coffee on Twitter if you know them but
hackathon is really really nice
environments to do so because you
basically you have like day or two to
spend to spend with people who actually
contributed to scikit-learn for a long
time so the next thing you should do is
to fold the repo into a github account
and start exploring issues targeted by a
good first issue or Help Wanted as their
easier to start with also there is a tag
called documentation which is useful for
beginners and if you're really keen on
writing documentation it can help you to
start getting into open source
contribution so if you're not sure if
your choose an issue has already been
taken you should go and look under the
pull requests tab for it and if your
issue is not there you can start working
on it by going back to the issues tab
and writing a comment that you're
starting to work
it's in a comment section so
communication is really important you
should write down everything that you
want to do but if you're still not sure
about whether you should start working
on your chosen issue you should go to
the git er development channel and ask
people for anything you wonder so you
can you can ask questions anything
related to development or anything else
you're not sure about or if you really
shy about talking publicly then you can
think anyone in a private chat they're
really they reply really quickly and
they really want to help you and to talk
to you so you should address any
problems you have in the github comment
section so for example this is this is
an example of me tagging the person who
I want to review my code after I tag tag
this person other people also started to
to comment on my code and you need to
listen to them and you need to adjust
your code accordingly when you're done
coding you need to make sure that you
added new tests or that you have
adjusted the old ones so before you can
merge your codes with master all of your
tests need to need to pass otherwise you
won't be allowed to merge so this is the
this is an example of tests which are
not passing so at this point you cannot
merge your code and you need to keep
talking to other contributors and to
make changes to your code until all of
your tests are passing when you when you
pass all of your tests
then people will usually tell you if you
need to make additional changes so this
is an example when a person tells me
that I should see a minor comment below
but otherwise it looks good to him and
it's ready to match and
[Applause]